[Music]
no tsuita wife episodes on fineö
you were on the naughty list this year
[Music]
oh hello internet and welcome to a
special holiday edition of film theory
if the songs are to be believed it's the
most wonderful time of the year and I
would have to agree
assuming you ignore all the travel woes
family stress brutal cold and rampant
consumerism of December so for our
holiday special this year I thought I'd
take a break from intensive pixel
measurements of the Hulk's big toe to
look at something with a bit more
holiday cheer the stop-motion claymation
Rankin and bass movies from the 1960s
and 70s depending on who you are these
are either on your television every
Christmas season or continue to haunt
your nightmares every time you go to
sleep a Scott cough and now that the
five nights at Freddy's series is done I
think I found you some new horror game
potential here these movies which
include Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer
Santa Claus is coming to town a year
without a Santa Claus and Jack Frost all
along with their sequels comprise one of
the earliest cinematic universes in
known history literally decades before
Marvel made it a thing that we all talk
about the producers Arthur Rankin and
Jules Bass United their holiday movies
around a series of recurring characters
and themes complete with nods sequel set
ups and easter eggs across all the
movies so what secrets could a half
century old slate of children's holiday
movies possibly hold oh I don't know how
about Santa Clauses biggest secret an
untold Claus family tragedy is the movie
Santa Claus is coming to town
it's established that Santa Claus
himself was abandoned as a baby and
raised as an orphan but what if Santa
lost himself a child of his own a child
who like himself would also have to be
raised as an orphan it would be like
Star Wars it would ride
well that is my theory today that Santa
Claus literally lost his young son a
poor young boy who had braved the cold
of the North Pole and against all odds
grow up to become the intrepid explorer
Yukon kornelius tis the season to write
theories fala Lala la la la let's go
he's your family holiday traditions
don't include spending 40 minutes
struggling to get
ancient VHS player hooked up to your
modern TV Jessie you can play a version
of Rudolph your dad reported back in
1989 commercials and everything
including that original clapper
commercial from way back then or in the
likely event that you were born sometime
this millennium and have literally no
clue what these stop-motion creep shows
are all about well all these 45-minute
movies are available for free on YouTube
right now seriously links to all of the
movies are in the I cards and upper
right hand corner of the screen so grab
a blanket some Christmas cookies a loved
one and curl up next to the fireplace
and watch some Christmas classics with
the family this theory will still be
here when you're done just pause it or
subscribe I don't know so hurry back
filled with the warmth of love and
family and a little bit of sugar cookie
great but for all your Scrooge's who
didn't click let me give you the quick
much-needed refresher Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer had a very shiny nose
and in true Christmas fashion got old
school sirens wait for it prompting him
to run away he winds up at Santa's shop
one foggy Christmas Eve and guides the
slave at night prompting all the
reindeer to love him and shout with glee
proving once and for all that timeless
holiday message your physical
deformities are only societally
acceptable if they serve a useful
function hey that is a Christmas classic
talking not me and the rest as they say
went down in history so that's the story
we all know from the song but along the
way in this movie we meet Yukon
kornelius the Arctic prospector who
helps Rudolph and the aspiring elf
dentist hermie in their quest of
self-discovery Yukon meanwhile is on the
hunt for something else
banes hoping to strike it rich and also
hoping not to get his tongue stuck to
his pick if that were to happen we'd be
in a very different Christmas movie but
watching this movie as a kid I could
never get over how weird these moments
were and not just because of that
licking sound effect I mean think about
it he throws up his pick and then starts
licking it
why is he able to taste silver and gold
his pick is metal so wouldn't that also
taste like metal well here's the thing
he actually isn't looking for silver and
gold in a scene that appeared only
during the original airing of the film
and has only started to re-emerge a
newly printed home copies you got has
revealed to have been looking for
peppermint the whole
time now all those licking sessions with
his axe make a whole lot more sense he
can taste the peppermint you can't have
forgotten what he was really looking for
until he tasted it why does that matter
well you got says he's been searching
for this his whole life except there's
one problem with that peppermint isn't
something that exists underground it's a
plan that gets processed into hard candy
with the one and only exception being
this peppermint Bane that just so
happens to be right outside Santa's
workshop and yet somehow Yukon got it
into his head that if he digs around he
could just name the candy it's almost
like he has some childhood history
living at the North Pole around these
underground peppermint loads and then
somewhere along the line wandered off
hitting himself and his memory loss now
consider this throughout the movie Yukon
repeatedly saves the crew from the
abominable snow monster or what he likes
to call the bumble they always thought
that bumble was a strange term for this
legitimately terrifying creature
especially when other characters
expressly call it the abominable snow
monster but bumble sounds exactly like
what a small child struggling to say the
word abominable might spit out and it's
not like he uses it as a nickname for
the monster it is actually what he calls
it it's even in the script bumble snow
monster
[Music]
this odd vocal tic could be from him
learning the word as a child but never
learning the correct pronunciation
because he was lost before someone could
correct him now as a full-grown adult he
still talks like a child because he was
lost as a kid and had no parents to
raise him but why would I go so far as
to say that his long-lost father is
Santa
well let's start by looking at Yukon and
his potential father side-by-side that's
a pretty decent family resemblance but
it actually goes way deeper than this
remember when I said that this theory is
all about the whole Christmas cinematic
universe well Santa Claus is coming to
town is the prequel to Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer and you should look
at Santa in that film that red hair is a
telltale sign that Yukon happens to be
Santa's son because in the entirety of
the rank and ambass universe there is
only one other person with red hair and
that person is mrs. Claus in all of the
other scenes from Santa Claus is coming
to town none of the other villagers have
red hair I mean look at all those dark
haired children on top of all of that
it's strange to see Yukon kornelius
wandering around the North Pole because
well people walking around the North
Pole is just not that common in this
Cinematic Universe according to the end
of Santa Claus is coming to town Santa
chose his workshop to be at the North
Pole specifically to avoid people coming
to capture him because by that point in
the movie he was a wanted criminal yep
you're that one right Santa is a
fugitive
are you making oh oh
holy moly these movies are strange
that's even without me mentioning that
acid trip scene like I said look at the
iCard if you want to watch any of these
you can being Santa Sun even works
thematically Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer is all about the characters
finding themselves yukon finding riches
and silver and gold mines just wouldn't
make sense based on the themes of that
story the true riches that he would find
under this theory is that he would find
his home again and also last last note
here the producers rank and ambass
really do love their lost orphans it's
not just Anna but it's also the little
drummer boy and also Lucas from the 1975
special the first Christmas a story of
the first Christmas snow a redundant
title if I've ever heard one about an
orphan who loses his eyesight so anyway
Yukon would definitely fit in this
lineage of characters as the prospector
who loses his parents and his memory as
a child so let's just lay out all the
cards on the table we have a man with a
missing memory but knowledge of
underground peppermint veins running
around the abandoned North Pole where no
one else is talking like a kid and
sporting neon red hair in a world where
no one else does all in a story about
finding your place in the world but
there is one last clue one last little
hint left at the end of Santa Claus has
come to town that seals the deal that
Yukon is Santa's long-lost in during the
credit role of Santa Claus is coming to
town as the mail truck drives around
Santa's castle in the North Pole we get
this a short clip of a redheaded child
playing with a toy and Santa's Castle I
don't know about you but that's a small
redheaded child living in the North Pole
who by the time of Rudolph
is completely missing Yukon kornelius
the son of Santa destined for greatness
but reduced to a side character in
another hero's story but hey that's just
a theory Oh Christmas theory and jingle
jingle jingle jingle there's also
another video about another orphan so
bring me some new subscribers by
clicking right here
[Music]
you